hi I'm Dennis octave and my project is
about bringing down large-scale Networks
so in the news we see a lot of examples
of security breaches and network
vulnerabilities as an example the
stuxnet and the Hartley blogs are
recently came up as a very Major Impact
on networks and very recently the
Chinese breached all the USPS servers
which led to many passwords stolen and
many details stolen about the US USPS
servers but the problem is many of these
attacks are unreported undiscovered and
a lot of these different types of
attacks rely on different type of
different scale of attackers so as an
example the PlayStation Network outage a
couple of years ago led to 77 million
accounts being stolen but the attackers
needed to take over a third of all of
Amazon EC ec2 in order to carry out this
attack
and the problem is current academic
literature characterizes the network
Securities uh vulnerabilities as well
vulnerable or not vulnerable there's
this binary characterization that we
really need to change because different
types of vulnerabilities really require
different scales of resources in order
for the attack to be carried out
so we need to lay down a common
framework which is uh this example I'm
giving here
um if we can generate a graph for
different vulnerabilities for that
measures the fraction of the damage
times the C of the CPU seconds so the
number of processors some number of time
will actually be able to get a good idea
of what the current Frontier of network
security looks like so when designing
more new networks we'll be able to push
this Frontier we'll know what types of
areas to focus on
so we already know that the internet is
vulnerable because
um there's been a lot of research on the
topology of networks and the internet is
roughly known to be a scale-free network
model and the scale free network model
um has the property of the skill free
network is that there are some certain
highly connected clubs such that these
hubs removal of these hubs can lead to a
highly partitioned Network very quickly
so as an example we have a toy example
of a typical ISP Backbone in which all
these nodes correspond to different
routers in the ISB backbone and we see
that the removal of only three routers
can lead to a complete partition of the
east side and the west side of the
United States so and to generate a toy
example we created this chart
we assume that all the routers were
encrypted with sha-1 with passwords
around eight or nine characters and we
created this chart and we saw that in
order to even uh even in order to even
um destroy 15 of the entire system we
only really need a distributed system uh
which um running for an hour or two uh
brute forcing passwords and we already
saw that loss of three nodes can lead to
a complete partition so the network is
vulnerable and
with these characterizations with these
um with this common framework we'll be
better able to understand the impact of
networks security attacks